我的手是犯着晃的
但是我的练士感觉是那种
很通透的白
他们每个月做出来的
没有什么区别优
那里没有发现每一次
在每个月弄完都不理解
赶快发的感觉
但是自己在家里面做
死发弄到的产品也很好
这些出带的效果
就是差了那么一点
然后我就研究了一下发现
其实我们说说
估计了得挺小重点
就让每个月转到我们那么多的钱
我们掌握了这个圆密
也可以自己在家里面做
我叫他家庭版
几乎贯住
你们不需要跟我用一样的产品
我只是跟你们分享我的这个方法
你们用自己的产品
出来的效果
原谅是融光款的
马上叫过年了
赶快试试
第2天
虽然你的所有亲戚
我们做几乎贯住之前
一定要打开
皮膚通道
这个是非常重要
但是却被我的红绿的衣服
给你们看一下我现在凉
就是我的融头
还有鼻子
这一圈都被进了
有指督的言认识试试
就都是那种
比例理的感觉
你们看见的黑头
这个时候
你不管是什么
被你都被觉得很激烈
没效
因为婚婚
它图在里上根本就没有被皮膚吸收
它都被这些油脂给肚子带带带带带带带带
我们现在称得起来找毛孔
是张开的状态
赶快服务一个黑头导出现
我会把我毛孔都肚住的地方
然后都服上这个
黑头导出现
我这两边就比较名秘
所以这两边我都会服
服的时候一定要来一个热盆
如果你没有这样的热盆
已经就去用锅
稍微点水
用热气去蒸脸
但是不以表会他们导入
好
大概蒸了个15分钟
现在开始产脾几分钟
我们就一定要清清楚了这种产
就可以了
好
我刚刚已经炒完了
然后已经发炼洗干净了
现在的皮膚通道已经打开了77%了
我们现在再用一个
这种酸的动物
再来出一下
这一步其实服务3到5分钟就可以了
这是为了进步再一次打开
只有皮膚的通道
这就不错完了
我们的皮膚通道采算是真正的被打开
像那种非常高端的法式院建育法
他们基本上都有这一步
这一步的话
他们是叫做调一脚汁
调理完了之后
我们再去冠冲
就能够把营量全部都冠净皮膚的
这才是真正的有脚护服
我们先用一个有酸酥酥反尚火的
伤不适合
再来一会
第三面
如果是不想拍的话
也可以用少不适来做一个什么
第二步在有一个精华做单体
如果是觉得最近皮膚比较干脏
就可以用这种皮膚精华油
如果是感觉皮膚比较安华
就可以用这种可以体量的精华
那么我觉得最近皮膚博你也可以用这种修顾精华
但是这就是切剂这个精华
不要弄那种很刺激的像是吧
算啊
一传的员心被CN这种通通都不可以
我想想明天放上我的两个白鸡
所以我刚才就用这种可以这样的精华
就是在用一个通过面膜
这个通过面膜
然后我们可以以后
一定是我们关锋的重水素
在来附上一片天片膜
这个面膜就用那种很甜
一本那种浮水啊
就获得那个面膜
那些过者是用那种广泉水
配合那个植膜去正式面膜也行
这也不能主要就是为了增加这个夹茶
让皮膚感这个營料都
但是说你千万感觉皮膚全
不全霍把那些營料都吃进去
不用皮膚做了
这种最好还是用清水洗一下
就是避免營料过程的家庭
所以放到肯楼
现在可以开始
不够去的不够
看我的面膜的少数是我的少数
但是我的面膜感觉是那种
好痛痛的感觉
刚才已经被换住过了
现在我们不用水了
我们现在直接就不用喝
我还敢说
就我们开始用的是什么型码
现在我还是用什么型码
再用一个你喜欢的
修护或者是黑老棉生
还是你通常现在感觉皮膚非常地水
那很难切
很有光符
我每个人做出来的没有什么区别用